ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا
عميد الياس نود ان نعرف الفرق بين صواريخ
كاليبر التي تقول القوات الاوكرانيه لانها
اصبحت قادره على اسقاطها والصواريخ الصوت
او فرض صوتيه التي تقول بانها تحد فعلي
للقوات الجويه الاوكرانيه والمضادات
الارضيه فعليا ما الفرق بينهما وهل هو
مشكل عتاد ام ربما التطور العسكري لا يسمح
بصدها حتى الان
محمد الكلببر اصبحت عاد تعودت عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه ولديها وسائل الاسقاط
هذا لا يعني انها تذهب بسرعه اقل من الصوت
نحن حتى نتحدث عن الفرد صوتيه على امرين
مهمين كم اسرع من الصوت سبعه الى عشر مرات
وبالتالي المسار الذي يتبعه الصاروخ الفرد
صوتي وهنا تبدا التحديات الدفاعات الجويه
على سبيل المثال فوق كيف يقال انه تم
اسقاط الفرد صوتي
بصواريخ الباتريوت وهذا الامر ليس متوفرا
على كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه الاولويه اليوم
للحمايه هي الكييف وليس لي اوديسا
وبالتالي هذا امر مختلف من هنا هناك ما
يسمى بالتقنيه المتطوره والكميه الروسيه
مقابل النقص في الدفاعات الجويه القادره
على اسقاط الفرد صوتيه
واضح اذا العميد الياس يعني كيف يمكن وصف
المرحله الان يعني الكل يتحدث عن استخدام
مسيرات وحرب مسيرات وكل طرف يحاول ان
يتصدى لاكبر عدد منها في اي مرحله نحن من
هذه الحرب اذا
ليلى المسيرات اليوم المسرح الاوكراني هو
المسرح الاول اليوم لتصنيع اختبار تعديل
وتحديث واستعمال الزكاه الاصطناعي على
الساحه الاوكرانيه 200 شركه يوم تعمل في
هذا المجال هناك جيش اوكراني
للمسيرات وهناك جيش روسي حديث للمسيرات
على الساحه الاوكرانيه ثلاث ديناميكيات
اليوم
ليلى الهجوم الاوكراني على ثلاث محاور في
مخمود في
سلكه نوفو سيلكا وفي اوريكيب والهدف دائما
هو قطع جسر البري هذه اول ديناميكيه
الديناميكيه الثانيه هي ضرب اللوجستيه
الروسيه والعمق الروسي من هنا جسر كرش جسر
شنهار
وبالتالي ضرب العمق في شبه جزيره القرم
والبعد الثالث او ديناميكيه الثالثه هي
التي تحدثت عنها ليلى هي حرب المسيرات هذه
هي الديناميكيه اليوم على الساحه
الاوكرانيه طيب لو نفهم اكثر فيما يتعلق
بهذه المسيرات تقول موسكو ربما قبل ساعات
فقط بانها استطاعت ان تحبط هجوم بطائرات
مسيره فوق مقاطعه كالوجا القريبه من موسكو
قبلها استطعت مسيرات ان تصل الى موسكو وان
التضرب ابراجا وناطقه في قلب العاصمه ما
الذي يجعل الدفاعات تتعرف وتكتشف وتسقط
بعض الطائرات المسيره وتفشل مرات اخرى
محمد ليس هناك من دفاع جوي مطلق مئه في
المئه هناك امكانيات مقابل مساحه كبيره
جدا تريد حمايتها اليوم كلوغا تبعد تقريبا
200 كيلو متر جنوب
موسكو وهي بعيده عن الحدود الاوكرانيه 300
كم فمن اين انطلقت هذه المسيرات وما هي
نوع هذه المسيرات اليوم نتحدث عن مسيرات
بيفر القندس
الاوكرانيه يصل مداها الى الالف كيلومتر
هل هي ماذا استعمل ام هي تطلق من الداخل
الروسي هذا السؤال السؤال الاخر هو هل
فعلا اسقطت الطائرات فوق كلوغا كانت
متوجهه الى موسكو ام كان الهدف كلوغا اذا
كانت متوجهه الى موسكو واسقطت في جالوجا
هذا يعني ان الجيش الروسي تاقلم مع الواقع
ووضع دفاعات متقدمه بعيده عن موسكو ولكن
في كل الاهداف تبقى اوكرانيا كالوجا او
موسكو رابح رابح لانه الموضوع هو موضوع
سيكولوجي اكثر منه عسكري شكرا جزيلا لك
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري هو
الاستراتيجي كنت معنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]